Được là quán nghệ an ơi, chương học không đề thoại của như chỗ về tự thơ của ta biết.
Tự kết thức kể quy định, học sinh nói không với đề thoại trong buổi học, như chương học ở nghiệm an không còn cảnh học sinh tục năm tục ba,
cảm quý vật để thoại trong tự ra chơi, có lẽ từ đây sẽ có ít đi những học của thảo của mặc xác hội,
hãy các ai đồ tích tóc mặt đồng phục, những sức đề thoại thông mình tạm lươi về sau, nhưng chỗ thử tự thời trên thật cho những trò chơi thân xát đồng về hiếp.
Không còn mà hình sẵn dự, không còn phải chạy đôi đến tiêm, đến công man,
tất cả các bạn đợi qua mình và tỷ sự của thử thơ với nè dây,
ôn quán hẹn bảo vụ, những chừng học nói không với tự thại của như an,
giờ đây channe đây tự kể sòn tăng, những kài ông vô tư và đôi mắt lấp lạnh nhìn vui,
như chỗ thành ghi gạnh quên thuộc hơn,
và đó, các em không chỉ vui chơi, mặc con gắn kết,
học các sẽ chia vào lưới lên cùng nhau, chẳng yük về đẹp sản gì như vô cùng bị giữa của thử học cho.